for right now like i'm just
living in the moment and i don't have
any expectations i
you know there's no labels there's none
of that it's just
people that
make each other feel better julia fox is
opening up about her romance with kanye
west it was really surreal during the
latest episode of her spotify exclusive
podcast for bitten fruits the actress
dishes with her co-host nikki takesh
about the rapper and their strong
connection our minds we both like work
very fast like i talk very fast and i
can have ten trains of thought and like
whatever what's really exciting about
him is that like any idea can become a
reality like anything is possible any
dream is possible and i love that and
he's just such a doer he's like
do it now you know yeah don't wait julia
says yay has also introduced her to his
world of music
and it's honestly just an honor to be in
the presence and to be able to
um to experience history happening like
even being in the studio
um with him in future yeah and listening
to the new songs which by the way are
insane
that's really cool i love
like music has saved my life on many
occasions and for people who have
commented on the two's mental health the
uncut gemstar had this to say yay has
been open about his mental health
struggles and i feel like i have been as
well and we all have as we should be
nothing i feel like i feel like we need
to like destigmatize it and stop shaming
shaming us like what the hell we didn't
ask to be
born this way so what do julia's friends
think of her new relationship like to
the people that know us both personally
like all the people that we have in
common like friends and comment have
texted me and been like oh my god this
makes so much sense julia also circles
back to being a big fan of kanye's ex
kim kardashian and her famous family
after comments she made on the podcast
in december recently resurfaced i'm
gonna miss keeping up i've been watching
keeping up since it first
came out in like 2007 when like watching
it was embarrassing yeah me and julia
are like die hard kardashian fans
wanted them to be my family even though
the internet is having a field day with
it julie is still standing by her words
and owning it also like
okay who wasn't a fan of the kardashians
okay like i'm not like die hard like
stand in line in the cold or like go to
like a store opening i don't even own
one lip kit you guys know it's not
really that serious the milan native
also talks about her connection to the
beauty mogul's new boot pete davidson
and goes into detail about their 2019
paper magazine shoot together it's funny
to like see where people go with their
conspiracy i saw some crazy conspiracies
i love the paper magazine cover of me
and pete oh yeah that's that shoot that
we did and we're the i don't know why
people are really
obsessed with that because it's meta
right right okay because now like the
two most famous people in the world are
like right
right i'm like everyone was like oh my
god they're all like that's not that
weird like yeah yeah but we're all we
were all connected even prior you just
gotta roll with it so just how serious
are ya and julia well earlier this week
a source told et that they're having a
good time hanging out and are getting to
know each other better but the source
adds when it comes to kanye's
larger-than-life courtship style well
it's for a reason quote connie is trying
to make kim jealous by being very public
with julia he's trying to make a point
of course this all follows the two
steamy photo shoot during their date
night in new york city which interview
magazine shared photos of i mean it was
just fun just do something for my heart
so what does julia think of yay trying
to make kim jealous she doesn't mind our
source says julie thinks kanye is really
cool and is also just enjoying the ride
while it lasts but there's one thing
julia wants fans to know she says dating
kanye is 100
real i mean there's always people that
think that like every single celebrity
scandal is a is a setup i personally
don't i'm just living my
life guys